Speaking of white privilege,
I have to share with you this because I,
I'm,
I'm still in shock even though
it happened a few years ago.
So when I was supervising students in
my last position as a counselor to a
women's shelter,
we had a few students every year you
always get students from George Brown
because they have that
very specialized program.
It's basically specializing in being
a counselor for assaulted women and
children advocate.
My students told me that within
the first week of class and the,
I don't know if this is being
done in all their classes,
but certainly one or two of their classes,
all the white students were asked to stand
against the left side of the wall and
all the students of color rosters
and on the right side of the wall.
And then each and every white student
had to basically take a step forward and
talk about a,
how they benefited from white privilege
and be almost like groveling and
apologizing for what they,
for all the people of color.
That assistance.
Yes,
I have to get it.
And I kept saying to them like,
what?
Like I was so shocked and stunned
when I heard this and these are 17,
18 year olds coming into you.
Uh,
many of them were actually sort
of coming in from the suburbs.
They were very sheltered and they
weren't even exposed to urban life and in
their first week of college
to be exposed to this.
I found it reprehensible and I
was telling my friend about it,
who's also a social worker.
She told me she went to George Brown and
while she was waiting for the professor
to finish with her lesson before
she was going to speak to the class,
the professor reprimanded the class and
said that even if Xiang Ghomeshi was
found innocent,
we believe women period,
that that's,
that's her position and that
should be the classes position,
so no respect for the law whatsoever.
What do you see that with the Ontario
Human Rights Commission to which has
placed itself outside normal
jurisprudential practice
because the people who run
those organizations are convinced that
English common law is nothing but an
oppressive patriarchal institution,
which is exactly count runs
exactly counter to the,
to the reality of the situation.
English common law is an amazingly humane,
amazingly humane,
evolved system.
And,
and it's,
it's one of the world's
great achievements.
To think of it as a tool of
patriarchal oppression is absurd.
Beyond comprehension.
Yeah.
But,
but then,
but Dr. Peterson,
so then what happened is when a
couple of students put up their hand,
I mean,
this is a bloody college,
you're supposed to engage in dialogue,
in rigorous debate and sort of said,
oh,
by the way,
this man was found,
he was acquitted,
and we kind of have a legal system with a,
once you're acquitted and the
professor just blasted them and said,
no,
regardless of the decisions
made by the court,
it is her position and she wants it
to be the classes position that he is
guilty.
The verdict has no relevance.
Yeah.
Okay.
That is terrifying to me because it also
speaks to the whole title nine what's
happening in the u s and other like,
um,
this is very terrifying.
This is absolute indoctrination.
Yeah.
Well you ran,
one of the things that you have
to add to this sort of debate as,
I mean,
I know that your family's
experience in Canada,
it was really pretty damn harsh.
I mean,
if I remember correctly,
your dad was one of the first people
to wear a turban in Toronto and it was,
you guys had the misfortune
of moving into a pretty rough,
uh,
working class neighborhood where there
was some thugs after you won a fairly
regular basis.
I know that you were featured in Macleans
magazine on the cover consequence of
all the,
I would say,
persecution that you endured and you
were just a kid when that was happening.
Yep.
My Dad was one of five men in
a turban and this was 1970s,
Toronto and we were living in
sort of east Toronto at the time,
the pape and Danforth area,
but south of there.
Uh,
and our home was vandalized and cars
trashed and we were constantly bullied and
attacked.
And my dad was denied a job as a
security guard at George Square because,
because he wore a turban.
Um,
but here's the thing,
like my dad,
my family that happened in
the seventies and eighties,
but we have never ever had a
problem in the last 25 years.
We have equal access to everything.
I mean,
Jag meets thing is wearing a turban
and he's the leader of the NDP.
So Canada has changed drastically.
And if I had to choose another
country in the world to live in,
I wouldn't choose one.
I can't imagine a better place to live.
So yes,
horrible things happened and we were
in Maclean's and we suffered immensely,
especially my dad.
Um,
but this is what's
amazing is Canada is now,
I'd say like probably the
least racist place on earth.
Yet there are some people who are adamant
that we are still living back in the
fifties or sixties when things were
unbearable for people of color.
And that's just not true.
And when I pointed out it's just not
true and I know it because I've lived it.
I'm told I suffer from internalized
colonialism and internalized racism.
That's the classic leftist argument
to anybody who fits one of their
hypothetically victimized groups
who dares to stand up and say,
ah,
wait a minute.
That's actually not been my experience
and I'm really happy to be living here.